look at how far this franchise has come
they've gone from a bunch of street
racers doing their street racing thing
in a movie that was pretty much Point
Break with cars so now a bunch of cars
taking on a battle tank and a plane that
is cinema escalation right there
fast and furious 6 so fast in fury 6
takes place after fast 5 I thought fast
5 was awesome they found a really cool
niche with this whole Fast and Furious
thing in which they took fast and
furious and made it a heist movie a
really sweet heist movie now the crews
all live in large they got their
millions of dollars life could be worse
than being a millionaire but now there's
this other hotshot crew committing
crimes you know with cars and street
racing
now the rocks like there's only one crew
that can take out a crew criminals and
that's the other crew of hot rodding
criminals that I know so he gets Vin
Diesel and his crew and the rock goes to
Vin Diesel he shows him a picture of
Michelle Rodriguez who was dead now but
I guess she's not dead and she's running
with the enemies of Vin Diesel's like
you don't turn your back on family we
need to find out what's up and the rocks
are like and now we have our new movie a
pretty fun movie at that this isn't as
much of a heist movie as it is criminals
going after other criminals at behest of
the rock but the other criminals are
like worst criminals Vin Diesel and his
crew there's a lovable criminal so it's
okay for them the realm of illegal and
the realm of likable that they're two
different things really this movie
played a smart in which the criminals in
this movie are like the mirror image of
Vin Diesel's crew you know they're like
the Dark Link and Vindi so screwed
they're all the good links and if you're
an avid Xbox player and you didn't get
that reference as a Legend of Zelda
reference but don't worry judging by
Xbox one's big unveiled it's only a
matter of time before you come to the
good side of the force and leave all
that behind you Fast & Furious 6 gives
me a little bit of what I really liked
about Fast Five but it does cater to
what made Fast and Furious big in the
first place cool cars awesome chases hot
chicks you can't deny this movie has
some really exciting I mean like I
said cars are chasing down and taking on
a battle tank in the scene and then they
have to take down a plane which they
showed in the trailer and they shouldn't
have shown that I'm just saying doesn't
make it any less badass and the movie
does a good job at incorporating story
based elements into a story based
elements that tie back to the other Fast
& Furious movies there were a couple of
calls that were made in the movie in
which case you're like I don't know why
the whole Michelle Rodriguez thing as a
whole is one of those situations why is
she back I don't know just to have her
back unless you're Agent Coulson if
you're dead stay dead this movie had
good comic relief too in a movie like
this where you have a big crew you need
to show that your crew does work well
together you can say they established
that in the previous movies and really
in Fast Five but this is a new movie so
you still need to remind people if they
work well together
comic relief as long as they don't
do it can be a good way to show that and
they did it pretty well and I like the
fact that the rock has to work with the
crew he was hunting down in the last
movie cool to see yes it was original
not at all
don't go into this movie thinking to
yourself well let's go see if Oscar
season starts early this year that would
be stupid Fast & Furious 6 set out to do
a job and it did its job pretty well the
job is to entertain you with fast cars
really high velocity fast pace that
makes you go I am having a good time not
as good as Fast Five that's for sure but
still entertaining I will say Fast and
Furious 6 is a good time no alcohol
required right so we're in week 3 the
summer movie season what do you think of
the summer movie season so far and what
movie are you looking forward to the
most could be movie that's already come
out who knows that's up to you whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more